I've not been working out regularly
regularly for several years now
obviously I'm fat and lazy but I want to
get after it so the question is should I
go all in level 9 destruction maximum
madness or ease into it at level 3
cruising addition all right well there's
a couple different approaches now when I
hear this first of all you you don't
want to get hurt right
and you also don't want to make yourself
try and do things that are so hard and
so painful that you can't do it
repeatedly yeah so if you just destroy
yourself Mac what do you say if you
destroy yourself level 9 destruction
maximal madness but then you can't work
out for two more weeks well guess what
what you do in the mean no let's say
realistically you got Dom's come sure
right delayed onset muscle soreness
let's say you did so many burpees that
your legs you couldn't sit down without
your legs being in pain so now don't so
you take so you take three days four
days have you ever had Dom's so bad that
you took four days off no okay let's say
you take three days off mmm what did you
do during those three days did you hold
the line did you stay on the path or
were you eating Cheetos yeah that's what
you were doing so if you destroy
yourself to where you can't stay on the
path that's not good you want to stay on
the path I think doing something that
you can handle or maybe something just
beyond what you can handle every single
day is more important so going at a
level not not cruising level not level
three but let's let's find a solid level
five where you can you're pushing
yourself I read a thousand words a day
when I'm writing and salute you do the
equivalent of that right the reason I
read cuz if I said okay I'd do it
tonight it just today I just have to
write five thousand words that's five
hours yeah will do I have five hours
today no I don't I can squeeze out fifty
two minutes though and get a thousand
words written that I can do so that's
that's what I think you need to do you
need to get consistent
if you bite off more than you chew then
you can chew your you might very well
choke on it so done so don't do that so
pick something realistic do people say
that that was the first time I heard it
so um if you bite off more than you can
chew you might choke on it did you make
that up or you get that from somewhere I
think well I just I don't know if I
think I made it up it's good but I'm
sure I'll like be like no this guy said
it in 1978 yeah it says the beauty of it
so pick something realistic like
something that you can handle and then
get after it then the other thing here
is he doesn't talk about his diet at all
and that's clearly equally important and
you have to change your diet if you're
gonna change your life and you're gonna
change your health so stop eating sugar
stop eating processed foods no more soda
and juices and no more Gatorade just to
start with or whatever it is whatever
that it is that you're doing whoever
asked this question whatever you know
what you're doing if you're eating
donuts and wrong don't don't eat donuts
anymore stop to stop eating those get
rid of that sugar sweetness craving
thing yeah and then just keep making
your diet cleaner and cleaner as time
goes by yeah
so that's what I think is there any time
that it's good because sometimes I think
it's good when people do go like alright
man I'm doing yeah like I whatever
happened they went up the staircase and
they they got all tired and they say you
know what I'm done yeah it starts
tomorrow but I think in those cases most
the time who was it who was it that we
were talking to talking to someone
someone that they are I was talking to
someone that their first thing they try
to do they couldn't do at all mmm like
they tried to run three miles and they
were like you know what can't do it
mmm can't run three miles oh it might
have been that guy there's a guy that's
losing a bunch of weight on the
interwebs oh yeah that's what it is I
think he's down in Texas but he's trying
to lose a lot of weight
and the first time we went try to go for
run didn't happen enough didn't happen
so he had to just run less I had to just
walk actually it starts long so yeah you
you start with what you can do but there
is a little bit of there is there is I
would try I would say this keep this one
in in the back of your mind there is the
whole thing of like you know what I'm
changing my life right now you go home
you get the garbage can out you bring it
into the kitchen and throw away the
Twinkies you throw away the pop-tarts
you throw away the that you pour the the
crappy soda down the drain and you get
on the path and you just don't look back
yeah that's a good thing to do too yeah
but again if that person's 300 pounds
they're not gonna be able to do I mean
they're gonna push themselves yeah they
could push themselves too hard yeah so
you just got to be careful yeah see and
then it's funny when when I'm kind of
looking at the question I'm like well
obviously want to start slow right
obviously but then I thought you hear
about these guys just like how you said
they just they throw everything away
they were like I'm a different person
right I think I think we're crossing
streams here or I am
there's diet and then there's like
workout
yeah because diet you can pretty much go
cold turkey today yeah it let's and you
may or may not be able to relate to this
but if you go straight extreme on your
diet like all of a sudden you're hit
with these the byproducts of changing
your diet especially if you'd like like
Mountain Dew every single day and you
just all of a sudden boom stop doing a
month you'll go through stuff that you
might not expect like the craving li-ion
free and minimal doses of mountain yeah
no yeah no I'm gonna say no you don't
need it yeah and I dig and you're gonna
go through withdrawals right yeah from
caffeine withdrawals and sugar
withdrawals you're gonna get the the the
keto flu and all those things are gonna
happen and it's gonna be rough but yeah
but don't just say it like that is gonna
be rough but that's all it bro seriously
if you go into that and you experience
these types of things and it's gonna
apply to everything by the way any big
change that you make where you you have
to
depriving yourself of these bad things
they've become kind of addicted to or
whatever you're gonna go through all
kinds of changes and that goes for
worked out too by the way cuz like just
the soreness alone oh dang okay
expecting the soreness oh I'm like tired
now because the workout like was kind of
hard it's like oh sure I wasn't
expecting that I was expecting to feel
great after my workout how everyone says
or whatever so you're gonna run into all
these little things that no one tells
you about and then it's like well I
didn't sign up for that little part of
it and then that little part and then
you're gonna go I got the diet thing I
think you're wrong
I think the diet thing I think if you're
good I think it's very I think it's
easier in fact to just be like I'm done
it's not like okay you know what I'm
only gonna eat a quarter bag of Cheetos
a day from now on I don't think that
works I think you gotta be like no no no
no cheat us not no Cheetos in my house
but I do think that you could work out
so hard that you're so sore that you
that you say oh man I'm just to like
kind of like the jujitsu question
earlier on like you could be what if
someone so sore that they can't do their
job
right and they're just sore all day at
work well that's not cool so I think for
diet you can you can go cold turkey or
actually cold steak or hot steak sir and
then I think for working out is the one
you you you figure out what you can do
and you push it a little bit harder but
you don't go level nine Maximum
Destruction badness I think you're wrong
respectfully in which part do you think
I'm wrong on the diet I think if you go
extreme with your diet
I think that it'll work for some people
for sure yeah but depending on who you
are but I think your moral if you go
extreme to the diet you don't like
slowly phase out it was you know it's
interesting I don't know if you remember
I read a letter a while back on the
podcast about a guy that had read way
the warrior kid and he like fixed his
life him and that guy did what you're
saying he just made little changes you
know he made little changes along the
way so maybe it's personal it's probably
personality in fact let's just go ahead
and say it's personality because some
people are gonna just have to get the
damn Cheetos out of their house all of
them yeah and some people say you know
what I'm only gonna have this
cup full of cheetos every day yeah and
even that's okay it but but here's where
you got to be careful you may lie to
yourself oh yeah and you can lie to
yourself yeah and even lie to yourself
only hey you know I don't really that
bad not that big of a deal today jiff I
just have n cups of cheetos yeah yeah
yeah in nine cups of cheetos later see
and respectfully I don't like your
Cheetos example why because you're like
I'm gonna allow myself cheat okay don't
allow yourself Cheetos that's not how
small of a change you're gonna make if
you're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore
you're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore I'm
saying like if you go extreme on your
diet let's say you but but wouldn't you
say what you're saying is hey I'm gonna
change my diet okay I used to eat every
day
I'd eat a whole bag of Cheetos mhm and
now I'm only gonna eat one cup of
Cheetos from the bag a day
yeah that's improvement it is important
it's a small improvement now and if I
could do that then why is that not okay
yeah okay if you choose to do that but
okay now we're going into the specifics
of a certain person's okay I think I I
would say this this is more along lines
what I'm thinking as far as specific
examples if you're gonna go if I'm gonna
eat one bag of Cheetos obviously that's
not all I'm eating I'm eating other
stuff I'm the small change is I'm not
gonna eat Cheetos anymore I'm gonna cut
out Cheetos that's it I'm still not
eating that good you know I'm kind of
Cheetos or let's say I get you don't
drive through every day three times a
day
okay I won't get drenched through any
more or all that's a big change
not necessarily depending on what you
get going from three Drive thrus a day
to to zero
how's that not a big jet it's a big cow
is going from like and there's certain
people actually I was talking to someone
the other day that had lost a hundred
and fifty pounds female and it was
interested her nutritionist she hired a
nutritionist and the nutritionist said
okay what are the foods you can't live
without yeah and we'll work around those
yeah a pretty cool thing yes and what
she said was I need cheeseburgers and
fries so
then what she got told was something
along the lines of okay you can have
cheeseburger and fries on Friday yeah
yeah right so the family instead of you
know this this whole thing of I can
never eat it now what I'm saying is
there are people and I think I'm one of
these people where it's like oh if I
have cheeseburgers and fries today well
then I might as well just get a mint
chocolate chip milkshake with it yeah
and if I did that tonight then you know
what tomorrow morning hey after you get
done training maybe if you know that
cheeseburger was good yesterday how
cloud so maybe it's my own personal
weakness but for me I'd prefer to be
just like all in the path yeah yeah
that's why the 8020 rule and I talked
about this in the Field Manual the 8020
rule maybe it works for some people and
I guess it does work for me but I'd
rather just be straight on the program
you know what I mean yeah and and then
and you know what you know Tim Ferriss
has that thing where or he's talked
about that thing where he goes six days
hardcore strict and then the seventh day
you literally eat whatever you want as
much as you can and ride that I have and
it's really really good yeah because you
feel really really good not only
physically but just about the whole day
I'm on the program and you kind of know
and on that on that cheat day you do
because the cheat did you eat whatever
you want and you don't feel any guilt at
all even when you're on the 8020 it's
like you have to be coming off a real
strong week to like be to feel good bill
cheese for free like cheaters are good
too yeah and that's really that bad of a
cheat day
fries then you're starting to go into it
for sure but like you know a cheap a
cheat day like a scam hilt
it'll be like for real like a whole
thing of donuts Reeboks a cookie yeah
whatever you want
straight-up whatever you want it's just
discussed here's the thing though with
when you when you start to eat healthy
and you then you try to eat a whole box
of donuts yeah after like one two three
maybe six eight doughnuts
you're gonna be like you know in six no
not easy
yeah that's six donuts at once oh my
gosh you know those I think they're
called Entenmann's old-fashioned there
little chocolate donuts no you know what
a little full-size don't trade up
they're kind of a little bit bigger too
you know okay you know can't even fathom
eating six don't know ever since I
started talking so much smack about
Donuts yeah I know I can't literally can
never have one again in my life yeah I
know you're not allowed 400 500
yeah they don't have a bite even if you
were like if someone is I can't just buy
like that when I was a little kid my
parents would buy the chocolate donuts
the hostess chocolates that were all
covered in chocolate and those things
are good yeah you can't even have one of
those again no no I did the six-day
cheap program no even then okay I can't
do it you know you know the
old-fashioned donut is right it's like a
donut with a hole in it right no oh it's
called old-fashioned donut they're like
um it's they're kind of glazed and
almost like a not they're not crispy but
they're kind of Hardy are hard and okay
on the outside and then they're regular
soft on that something say and they have
this glaze over them okay so I think
it's I forget the name I think it might
be in two minutes
but they have old-fashioned Donuts where
they're not as hard but they're kind of
hard and they're just paper
anyway those are my favorite ones and I
used to get chocolate milk and heat up
the chocolate milk that's like hot
chocolate and donuts and oh yeah easy
money
like I'll eat two boxes of those for
sure all right you student yeah
oh yeah so no point there is on the
cheat day you just go yeah no shame but
after the thing is you can't just eat
donuts four times a day or three two and
you just don't feel good like your
stomach gets all upset and the more
healthy you eat the more it's gonna be
like that so the longer you're on the
path you straight like if you ate some
doughnut like the other day we went to
the Belmont Park and I ate some ice
cream some mint chocolate chip ice cream
was it good fine it was good but you
know all the kids are doing their worst
tracks the other night yeah you eat a
big large double you know what after
after that you're like but I don't feel
right you know so unless you're just
committed to eat it cuz I don't know you
don't know waste it or something like
that you're gonna be like all my cheat
your cheat day is not gonna be that bad
that's what I'm saying okay but I'm
still do that I don't make it happen
depends on what it is
yeah yeah you could pump some chili
fries or something I don't like chili
fries
all right so yeah maybe what's the
verdict I think just in there like
middle-of-the-road nut the the whole
story has it balanced so you're saying
balance as well I'll tell you though man
if that balance doesn't work for you
you're gonna have to step it up you have
to go hardcore I'd give yourself two
weeks two weeks for a balanced approach
on the diet side if you can't get your
shit under control in two weeks
you got to go hardcore you got to get in
there with a garbage clinic can throw
away the Twinkies throw away everything
else that's crap in your fridge and yeah
and go hardcore that go and start with a
fast to write a fast is awesome a fast
wait wait that much to expect you only
ever a day if you never done it before
it's not that big of a deal there's no
little stuff don't eat your deck there's
not take you from a normal human being
this little stuff they if you're not if
you go in and not prepared for it then
you're like oh I don't know actually
think the more you think about it
prepare for it the more psychologically
or it is yeah just to be like oh yeah
you know what I woke up this morning I
haven't eaten last night calm not gonna
eat until tonight every time I think
fast yeah so like that when I'm like I'm
not gonna eat til this then I go through
little stuff but if I just happen if I
be too into work right I'm only drinking
coffee and I forget I'm like dang if if
I eat not haven't ate for like you know
twelve hours or they'll be like oh I'll
just go another three that's my fifteen
cuz like fifteen or eight fifteen hours
is when your body starts to kind of
shift over to like I think fifteen okay
whatever eats clothes so I'll just wait
that shower it's like cool done but if
we plan it that's when yeah I don't know
but it depends on who you are man but
that's why I agree with the face off
yeah he's a good way to kick things off
and get like jump onto the path yeah
just jump on with a fast yeah hey go see
your doctor or whatever
you have to go see a doctor too fast 24
hours I think you should if you've been
probably yeah oh yeah fat lazy you know
especially if you're older or something
like that I think Cena does need a
personal trainer depends on the helmet
you know when I just talk to she's like
personal trainer and nutritionist hired
him both lost 100 whatever pounds so I
think she was in excess of 300 pounds
you know and when I met her she's
completely normal
right like you know completely like you
wouldn't even suspect that she had any
weight trouble in her life that's pretty
amazing yeah so higher the trainer
higher the the nutritionist yeah I think
so I think that helps I always looked at
it like why would I hire like a trainer
or something like that when I can kind
of look up that stuff but here's the
thing I went in with this bias like
because I kind of had a background in it
so I'm like why would I can just go look
but I'm looking it up but I have all
this other knowledge the same rule you
try it for two weeks
see if you can keep yourself on the path
and if you can't gotta bring someone in
right here's what I like hire a trainer
but not like the kind every day it's
like a once a week trainer who can get
you on a little program yeah yes you
know it's gonna depend on your
straight-up you know who can keep you on
yeah that's the biggest barrier all this
and I've said this a billion times like
you know what you need to do yeah you
know what you need to do you know you
know what you need to do if you can't
get yourself to do it maybe you need to
give someone to help you do it yeah the
weird thing is like nutritionists and
stuff you can get nutritionist that
could come to you Mike okay we're gonna
go put you on a low-fat diet you know
which would be really not good thing you
in the long term yeah I don't know how
many you think they're still
nutritionist that are doing that right
now oh yeah there are I know there are
actually they're all in there out there
so you gotta be careful right check next
question
last thing that I'm not gonna draw it
out but you said you know what you need
to do and one time you said imagine what
your day would look like like if you'd
like everything you did was you did the
things that you knew you're supposed to
do kind of thing well the the full the
full statement is if you wrote down
tonight what you were supposed to do
tomorrow yeah and then you did the
things that you were supposed to do yeah
yeah
imagine how that day would feel and
imagine what you'd get done in that day
yeah and then imagine if he did that
every day for a week
yeah and imagine if you did that every
day for a month and they did for a year
and imagine where your life would be
your life would be in a completely
different trajectory completely
completely different yeah and that's
true with working out that's true with
nutrition that's true with business
that's true with education that's true
with knowledge it's true with everything
everything yeah kind of know what we're
supposed to do yeah I thought you were
gonna say some people don't know what to
do and that could be the case some
people they've never worked out before
and if you're a person that's never
worked out before you probably need to
bring someone into the game that's gonna
help show you how to work out if you've
never done any reading about eating and
you have no idea what's gonna be good
for you
you're probably a person that might need
to bring someone into the game to help
you get over that yeah and it still
completely goes with exactly what he
said it's like you know what to do and
even to help that you know what not to
do like when you're about to make a
decision I'm gonna do this or not do
this like you know which one is you
should or shouldn't do so let's say I
don't know anything about working out
but I know I have to get in shape we all
know and you know we all know when we
gotta get in shape so then you know
you're gonna hire somebody you know you
gotta do something you know that you
might and just be like oh well I'm not
gonna do it I don't know I'm not gonna
do things to do tomorrow yeah in a
trainer yeah join a gym get a trainer
yeah I don't know what to do okay this
is way you could do find out what to do
there you go in that case so you got
make sense sometimes you put things and
just say stuff just put it on the table
just starts to make sense